[Musique]
si on est en train de voir se développer
en temps réel des écosystèmes primaires
ça veut dire non impacté par l'homme
sans le contrôle de l'homme qui va ici
mettre des poissons là-bas mettre tel
espèce choisir l'espèce d'arbre et tout
là c'est la nature qui décide et puis
elle prend les meilleures décisions les
arbres qui supporteront pas les
conditions climatiques là ils vivront
pas les arbres qui se développeront ils
seront
[Musique]
adaptés
le retrait glaciaire sur terre est en
train de faire apparître plein plein de
zones humides et qui sont les tourb de
demain donc il faut les préserver parce
qu'elles ont un rôle extraordinairement
important et puis elles sont aussi
importantes parce que ces zones humides
sur terre ell permettent de séquestrer
du carbone pourquoi parce que toute la
matière organique arrive là-dedans elle
va pas être décomposée parce que dans
l'eau il y a pas assez d'oxygène et donc
peu à peu ça ça va nous faire de la tour
sur temps très très long ça fait du
charbon mais en tout cas de la tourbe et
donc ça c'est vraiment un
gigantesque lieu de stockage du carbone
sur
[Musique]
terre